boa tarde amigos
acabamos de receber uma lição do evento
futuro do brasil e vai atrás a escutar
une atentamente tudo porque os mais
novos sabem mais que os mais velhos e
agora vão ter que escutar um pouco o
passado que vai depois do futuro porque
é contraditória bom eu já fui novo no
morumbi já fui jovem jovem professor de
escola pública e há quase 50 anos atrás
eu percorria de escola em escola aquela
via sacra do professor que substitui
professor quando eu more quando fica uma
pessoa grávida e um dia já com algumas
dúvidas em relação aquilo que eu fazia
eu cheguei uma escola para estar três
meses e eu pensei vai ser agora que eu
vou começar a aprender a ser professor
era uma pequenina tenha cerca de 65 66
jovens das quatro séries e eu fiz a
pergunta que faz sempre
já naquela altura fazendo o que querem
receber o que querem fazer
vamos ficar a olhar pra mim como se eu
fosse um extraterrestre onde sou mais a
mesma
querem fazer é responder o profissional
é assim quem mandar mas eu pergunto a
gente pode fazer o que é óbvio que nós
queremos fazer ficam calados até que um
deus disse
bom se eu posso fazer o que eu quero eu
posso fazer uma redação uma composição
escrita se pode agora a morreu não o
professor tem que dizer qual é o tema
quando julgasse deixa depois do título
quantas linhas eu tenho de escrever seu
ápice é caneta teve para falar
escreva lápis e caneta o porto quiser
quantas linhas do quisermos escreve o
que quer escrever um pouco a pensar eu
posso escrever sobre a primavera assim
todas é ótimo e foi ontem as outras 60 e
tal e voz primeira era eu fiquei
assustado pelo couro toda a gente queria
escrever o mesmo escreveu para que ela
não escreveu haynes teste ele
o primeiro já lá vão quase 50 anos eu
lembro muito bem do qual era a escrita
é primavera título na primavera
a primavera é uma estação do ano a
primavera começa no dia 21 março acaba
no dia 21
a primavera chega os passarinhos e na
china seu gosto muito da primavera então
eu acabei do e lhe perguntei quem foi
que escreveu esse texto e sessenta e tal
braço levantado que baixar outra lhe o
segundo e eu lembro me deu é assim a
primeira a primavera é uma estação do
ano e agora com de perguntar a quem
escreveu e todos e ninguém vai baixar
meus amigos também devolver as folhas
verdes voltarem a folha e agora e fazer
uma redação
mas sou eu vou dizer qual é o tema
aprontando muito tranquilo eles o tema é
primavera op - já havíamos ela tem
regras
quais são eu fui ao quadro negro eles
nesse teste camponeses escrever sobre o
primavera não poderia escrever o que eu
vou pôr no quadro negro e escrever
a primavera é uma estação do ano a
primavera banespa seria nas minhas
flores a primavera começa no dia tal
negócio ficaram parados olhar pra mim
olhar uns para os outros até que o fez
assim que começou a escrever outros
leitores me cansou e começou a se
espalhar
foi um dos dias mais interessantes mais
vividos na minha vida profissional
quando acabaram escreveu os livros teste
ele os testes não sei ler o primeiro
acabei de ler e perguntei quem escreveu
os textos e uma criança e ganhou a sua
mão a autora criativa olhando pra todo
lado e assim até o último texto aquilo
portugal me imenso como as dúvidas se
aproxima e faltava aquelas crianças
autonomia intelectual
elas não aprendiam absolutamente nada
numa aula nada se aprende mas aprendi
outras coisas eu sei que nunca ouviram
dizer isso mas eu vou obter numa aula
nada surpreendente depois quiserem
na altura eu expliquei porque então o
que foi que aconteceu
passado algum tempo enquanto estiver um
lugar chamado escola da ponte
encontrei-me com outros colegas e com as
dúvidas todas provar
vamos nós encontramos três em uma escola
de dezenas de processos e resolvemos
realmente fazer perguntas básicas porque
é que nós damos aula é tão bem dada e
alunos que não aprenda uma pergunta
qualquer professor faz
nós chegamos à conclusão de que se nós
estávamos aula eles não aprendiam eles
não aprendiam porque não estávamos aula
tão simples
então o chão fugimos debaixo dos pés
porque nós éramos por susto dar aula
o que nós fizemos e continuamos dando
aula mas a quarta feira entre às 8 e 9
construímos um projeto o projeto de uma
escola escolas não são edifícios escolas
são pessoas
as pessoas são os seus valores e então
nós fomos verificar sempre nossos três
haveria valores comuns nos jornais
costumam nas nossas vidas e respeitamos
os valores dos outros começamos os três
prefeitos que não queria que eu estava
querendo que nós respeitamos a crença e
começamos eram três veloso que nós
partilhávamos autonomia responsabilidade
a solidariedade autonomia
nós já tínhamos tido essa experiência a
criança nascer a autonomia em termos
intelectuais cognitivos mas faltava no
resto
até que um dia conversando com os alunos
uma criança perguntou opções é pesado
que um ser vivo é que nas creches a
produzir ó mas eu tinha ensinado aquilo
durante muitos anos da minha aula
brindada com bons materiais e punha no
quadro negro o serviço é que o que nasce
cresce quando se move por gustavo uma
imagem de um cachorro vamos nos
manifestar mas naquela altura eu resolvi
fazer uma pergunta em vez de dar uma
resposta à pergunta é por quê pergunta
se isso o pessoal eu não concordo com
isso
aquela criança de oito anos a pôr em
causa aquilo que eu ensinava tanto
quanto eu fiquei um pouco zangado mas
perguntei com toda a paciência eu quero
não concorda comigo e eu disse o
professor pensa um pouco
se o ser vivo é o que nasce cresce e
produz imó
então eu não sou um ser vivo então não
reproduzir
nem morrer aquilo portugal um imenso
eu fiquei a pensar porque onde ensinava
besteira mas foi mais longe
é que entretanto nós começamos a fazer
algumas transformações e aparecem os
pais que chances eu vou tirar meu filho
desta escola porque pode tirar porque
este método não resulta de uma escola um
metro a isso não sei então se não sabem
é que saibam votar por causa disso e
sabe o que faz porque é uma professora
de uma escola do lado nós descobrimos
que o maior aliado um professor é o do
professor é o maior inimigo do professor
fase enfrenta o professor da escola
doado
aí eu perguntei ao pai mas vai levar
embora um bom eu não levo mas há outro
problema para o senhor diga é que agora
a minha vida um inferno mas porque
antigamente eu chegava a casa maicon
sabe eu sentava na poltrona ligava a
televisão começava a ver o meu programa
preferido mas não posso chegar à casa
minha filha vem ter comigo papai está na
cozinha ela não é tão criada vai
ajudá-la vai pôr à mesa eu fiquei
impressionado sair do banheiro papai
ontem deixar de torneira a pingar quase
estragava deixar todos a ser desta
década é um inferno acabado de jantar
que admiro o futebol que papai e mamãe
estava barbado vai ajudar a mãe era
palocci é um inferno
o que estava a acontecer transformação
social
então nós precisamos que o segundo
grande valor desse projeto
a responsabilidade não era só o fato de
eu ser como professora responsável pelos
atos do meu coletivo que uma um projeto
escola um ato coletivo
então partindo de valores passando para
uma carta de princípios
eu passei esses princípios da ação com o
projeto esse projeto fim uma visão de
sociedade uma visão da pessoa humana
exige um determinado tempo de jogador e
nós estávamos a perturbar aquilo que se
passava nas casas e nós fomos ao
encontro das casas com responsabilização
responsabilidade social
era uma cidade com problemas sérios o
rio estava poluído lixo por todo lado e
enfim um pai convidam para ir para casa
eu fui e na casa o pai convidam para o
ver um copo eu fiquei em pânico porque
naquela altura não sabia que era beber
vinho hoje eu sei o segmento de eventos
gonçalves governo um bom vinho
sob a água cafezinho chazinho subversão
copo de vinho novo teria mas o homem
encher o copo eu comecei a falar com o
papai eu não respondia mais tarde
mais tarde é que eu vi no boteco um
destino que dizia quem não bebe não é de
confiança então eu não eu não falar eu
não falava comigo que eu não devia eu
seja o que deus quiser porque não copa
do rei os lábios ela olhou me todo eu
também achei outra vez ao fim de 4 ou 5
cop eu passei a ouvir a minha voz assim
em león lá no fundo eu falar eu falava
não lembro que eu dizia até que agora
vem a teoria mais tarde eu percebi
porque no início eu e as minhas duas
companheiras projeto foi um dos
primeiros pois toda a escola do rio
quando vi o pagamento às transformações
china aconteceram naquela época não
tínhamos noção nenhuma do que era a
teoria temos base a barba
nós agimos por intuição e por amor com
qualquer outro professor
só mais tarde é que nós entendemos que
na teoria encontrei a explicação para
esse episódio
quando eu aceitei primeiro copo de vinho
e estamos ficando pelo pai
o mediador cultural quando eu fiquei
bêbado foi isso que aconteceu eu deixei
de falar do paradigma currículo essas
palavras que o pai não entendemos que a
gente utiliza e temos jordão
profissional aqui a diesel a tv e
acabando uma opinião mas cobra pergunta
então corra bem a seus professores
falaram muito bem então quero dizendo
isso eu não sei não entende nada então é
preciso realmente utilizar uma linguagem
que seja do código castrillon do código
elaborado está na teoria da relação
escola família
o que nós fizemos na responsabilidade
nós percebemos que o provérbio africano
que é preciso uma trigo para educar uma
criança teria sido posto em prática que
não poderia continuar a ver a escola e
comunidade em que a escola era o dono de
uma rede de aprendizagem chamada
comunidade de aprendizagem e que a
família escola como dizia a minha amiga
roseli ela tem que entender e
complementar
então o que fizemos entregamos a escola
à comunidade não tem da melhoria da
escola tem de haver uma comunidade à
parte com o projeto a partir dos irados
desejos e sonhos
sem descurar o que cada um tem de ser
dentro de seus méritos e dons e hoje
essa escola é referência em fim mas
chegados aqui eu gostaria de acrescentar
o terceiro grande valor ambiental porque
quando eu pensei em deixar a ponte ao
fim de trinta e poucos anos eu queria ir
para longe do brasil à união
eu encontrei no brasil aquilo que eu não
esperava mas falta ao brasil até o
terceiro grande valor que nós
continuávamos na ponte era autonomia a
responsabilidade a terceiros
solidariedade
eu encontrei um país desigual encontrar
emprego mas encontrou um país onde os
melhores teórico
existem tantas chances como vivos os
melhores projetos mas também maior
falastrões os piores projetos com
certeza o brasil é uma contradição
permanente
então quando eu senti isso eu percebi
que eu poderia ajudar a que o brasil
exerça um pouco de sobriedade entre si
na escola e na comunidade
longe da minha idéia de um portuguesinho
dizer ao brasil gado fazer mas eu fui
estudar os teóricos brasileiros
estou bem um ao outro de oliveira lima
estudei florestan fernandes também um
estímulo a seu estúdio paulo freire
claro anysio nasce estréia nise da
silveira milton santos ou filmando as
vendas lourenço filho a maioria animais
que lane uma platéia de autores que os
professores brasileiros não conhecem ou
não pratico que praticassem seria bem
diferente
o preocupa é que o brasileiro continua e
eu gosto muito de estar no brasil e
adoro o brasil não sai daqui que
continua em importar modas e teorias do
estrangeiro a síndrome de vira lata o
que está lá fora é bom que está fazendo
não presta quando está querendo é muito
melhor do que está lá fora eu sair
europeu conheço muito bem estados unidos
europa e fico muito magoado ver é
importar modo os estados unidos por
exemplo coisas que eu vi uma aula r da
empreiteira com aquilo é aula numa aula
não só pra nada turma não tem fundamento
legal nem legal nem científico sério não
existe porque o que é isso cristianismo
criança o século 21 com pessoas
incluindo a trabalhar no século 19 é uma
coisa esquisita então que eu vejo é que
começa continuamos a adotar é exatamente
a modas estrangeiros e pior do que isso
fala se do projeto mas que o projeto é
que estamos a falar
quando eu vi as escolas continuando a
dar aula turma série toda a estrutura da
escola devem da revolução industrial e
vejo que essas escolas em incluem
projecto projetos de educação para paz e
nós sabemos que hoje mais de uma centena
de brasileiros foram assassinados
projetos de educação para a cidadania e
nós vemos escândalos de corrupção
o projeto educação para a saúde nós
vamos assim cá e nós vamos à obesidade
mórbida nos jovens que é isto
não queremos projetos nós queremos é um
projeto um projeto país um projeto de
escola mas a escola tem de conseguir
novas construções sociais aprendizagem
substituir o velho modelo com as pessoas
doentes que leva a que os indícios
alfabetismo funcional sejam invadidos e
por aí vai
não quero falar do que está errado quero
falar do que está certo tempo atrás foi
uma escola cheguei a professora ea
diretora muito simpática senhora ainda
bem que o senhor sabe nós somos
construtivistas eu fico logo do petróleo
quando só assim o construtivista somado
soriano som e alceu também é
construtivista nossa destrutivo está
brincando ela não deve ter entendido
olhos mas nós fizemos projeto eu posso
ver top elaborou junto uma criança vezes
é melhor ainda disse então precisa fazer
um projeto eu estou bem para já um
pequeno parêntese
quando se fala em projeto fala que
domínio cognitivo aprender continua mas
o ser humano não é só isso é também
afeta emoção não é espiritualidade ética
que tanta falta faz estética mas eu só
vi a preocupação com o aprender o
conteúdo a criança pode estudar o que
quiser pois vem
mas por que estudar aquilo qual é a
idéia do projeto e jovem disse ter
estudado o tubarão entanto que nesta
altura não nunca este então porque não
quisesse ajudar é professora na semana
passada disse kryak um senhor e que nós
vamos fazer projetos entre a criança
terrível
então ela disso perguntou o que é que
nós criamos eu queria fazer um projeto
robótica então criei com a volta de
rafael é porque a turma queria maioria
robótica pessoas interagem tubarão toda
a gente na casa do barão eles mas quer
que a fizesse a pesquisa eles posso
fazer para se ver pode ver e eu olhei em
assim o tubarão pesquisa
o tribunal não pode parar de nadar abrir
parênteses conforme a gravura a nexxera
branco porque ele só deve estar gravura
anexa tá no livro dele e porque está no
livro não está aqui do exército o
parêntese está no livro
o projeto estava copiada vai perder
tempo porque o que eu vejo hoje na
educação é exatamente isso eu perder
tempo importante modas de fósseis
estrangeiros piaget disse não sei que
bigodes disso não sei que os meus alunos
na universidade eu disse eu quero lá
saber o que eles dizem sou fofoqueiro eu
quero produção do conhecimento e não a
produção do conhecimento não há produção
do conhecimento que depois coloco ao
serviço da comunidade
não existe existe réplicas existe um
acomodação cognitiva para uma prova que
não prova nada e ter um diploma
bom então resumindo já prestou
vestibular a questão
eu gostaria muito que o brasil que se vê
se que tem tudo o que precisa a imensos
projectos que nós estamos a acompanhar e
compromisso
o que o brasil precisa hoje mais nada é
perceber o ter o dom da autoestima e da
solidariedade para que este gigante é
chamado brasil deixe de estar
eternamente deitado em berço esplêndido
e percebi que aqui no sul está a começar
o futuro dele
no mundo muito obrigado